all right so what about the pitch clock
I like it I really do I kind of wish it
was I kind of wish it was 20 seconds the
whole time I think I think that would
make it a little bit easier I mean I
mean
I don't know how you feel about it but I
feel like the the 15 seconds with nobody
on base like
if you look down at all
it's like a 10 and you're like oh God
there's no time you know I think it's
dope I think it really has helped like
like last night I mean you guys scored
nine
and um
usually when that happens in so long
that's a long game keeps it moving yeah
but the game was still under three hours
yeah I mean it's great you get home eat
dinner right I think it shows how much
dead time like they're used like nobody
likes that four hour nine inning game
those would just those are just drag you
know and it makes the season so much
longer too where you're just like you're
out there like you said if you're
getting blown out or you're blowing
somebody out like the game kind of just
crawls and then
you know I kind of got a guy out there
walking around taking a minute between
pitches yeah you're just like come on
man like let's move let's move this
thing along but it's been good I think
it it was a little bit of an adjustment
period
um obviously you're gonna have the every
now and then you know you're gonna get
you're gonna be banged with the strike
or something something's gonna happen
but I think for the most part it's good
I've liked it so far so
staying on the pitch clock situation
what do you think about because a couple
guys got banged when they had their
going home party like so when I go back
to Boston
I'm just gonna have to take a strike you
know what I'm saying or or you know I
think they can submit they can now I
think they said I'm submitting it for
them
I feel good in that so I I I I think
that that's crazy how you gonna bang
somebody you know what I'm saying I just
feel like there should be some feel
there like it's not that hard to like
no like you're not trying to waste time
yeah you're not you're not there being
like Oh I don't care like I'm just gonna
I'm just gonna take five minutes before
I get in the box like obviously you've
won World Series MVPs for you know that
City and team like obviously they're
going to show you love just like when
belly came back and played you guys and
yep
um he got banged yeah we were all like
oh my gosh one of that none of us want
to take you know come on like
the umpires know what's going on like
they're not trying to and I don't know
if they just don't have a choice or what
the deal is but uh and that kid that
made his debut after 13 years in the
minor leagues like hey bud oh one yeah
that was crazy go get him that was crazy